[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans auditions
publiques tous les lundis à 19h30 sur la
chaîne parlementaire LCP Public Sénat
soyez les bienvenus une heure une
invitée ce soir Marlène Chapa bonsoir
vous êtes secrétaire détachargé de
l'économie sociale et solidaire de la
vie associative conseillère régional
d'Île-de-France
au programme ce soir pas de panique a
dit Emmanuel Macron face aux risques de
coupure de courant alors pourquoi le
gouvernement a-t-il pris le risque d'une
communication anxiogène ou perçue comme
telle la réforme des retraites Elisabeth
borne ouvre le débat en mettant la barre
haute à 65 ans là je l'égale de départ
pourquoi braquer d'entrer les syndicats
vous avez confirmé Marlène Chapa une
possibilité au suffrage universel projet
de réforme est sérieux à Paris Brigitte
boucher et Tamet vous interrogerons sur
les débats à l'Assemblée nationale les
plus brûlants Yves Thréard jusqu'où peut
aller le rapprochement avec LR Nicolas
Sarkozy encourage Emmanuel Macron
attendre davantage la main êtes-vous
d'accord les questions d'actualité avec
Vincent roux on va parler naturellement
malienne Schiappa dans quelques minutes
de votre travail notamment sur les
associations c'est aujourd'hui la
Journée mondiale pour le bénévolat
est-il en crise vous ne répondrez tout à
l'heure mais d'abord en introduction je
vous l'avais je voulais vous dire que on
vous entend peu mais en tout cas on vous
entend moins que sous le quinquennat
précédent alors est-ce que c'est parce
que les dossiers que vous traitez vous
exposent moins ou est-ce que c'est parce
que vous-même vous avez pris une forme
de recul par rapport au débat public
d'abord bonsoir merci de m'avoir invité
je suis ravie de répondre à vos
questions non il y a plusieurs éléments
d'abord quand j'ai été nommé en 2017
pour la première fois au gouvernement
c'est vrai que les Français ne
connaissaient pas ou peu en tout cas me
connaissaient donc j'avais besoin de me
faire connaître de défendre aussi mes
combats pour l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes et maintenant c'est vrai
quand on regarde les palmarès de
popularité des responsables politiques
je suis modestement je le dis assez haut
assez identifié en tout cas par les
Français j'ai moins besoin de me faire
connaître je fais la même personne je
vais pas vous dire pour citer Nicolas
Sarkozy j'ai changé mais j'ai été nommée
j'étais une jeune femme trentenaire qui
débutait dans la vie politique
aujourd'hui c'est mon deuxième
quinquennat mon troisième ministère ma
6e année comme membre de gouvernement
donc peut-être que je j'appréhende d'une
manière différente le système qui est le
nôtre dans lequel nous nous avons une
forme de maturation en tout cas vous
vous l'assumez merci d'avoir répondu à
cette question un peu personnelle
question un peu plus politique sur un
sujet que que qui vous touche l'équipe
de France est en quart de finale c'est
pas le football je vous dis le sujet qui
vous touche peut-être que si mais c'est
pas ça si elle poursuit son beau
parcours au Qatar Emmanuel Macron ira
soutenir les Bleus en tout cas on
l'imagine est-ce que sur place au Qatar
il doit avoir un discours public assez
clair sur les valeurs dans un pays qui
analyse l'homosexualité est-ce qu'il
doit assumer cela publiquement face aux
autorités catharynées plusieurs choses
d'abord en ce qui concerne le football
moi j'ai vu avec beaucoup de plaisir les
prises de position d'Antoine Griezmann
et je vois qu'il y a on dit souvent les
footballeurs ne prennent pas assez
positions moi j'ai vu au contraire qu'il
y avait plusieurs membres de l'équipe de
France qui avait pris des positions
contre l'homophobie partout dans le
monde pour la dépénalisation de
l'homosexualité et je trouve que ça
mérite d'être un peu plus souligné et
relayée ensuite le président de la
République a dit que il aurait vocation
à se rendre à des matchs c'est l'équipe
de France allait loin dans la
compétition évidemment on lui souhaite
c'est sa position de président de la
République et c'est vrai qu'en général
la ligne du président Emmanuel Macron
sur la diplomatie c'est vraiment le
dialogue bilatéral il l'a mené
d'ailleurs avec différents chefs d'État
je pensais à l'Iran au Qatar aussi mais
également à Donald Trump quand il était
président des États-Unis il a toujours
dit que les désaccords profonds se
discutaient les yeux dans les yeux en
face pas c'est que c'est la raison pour
laquelle il ne veut pas couper la ligne
diplomatique comme il le fait d'ailleurs
avec la Russie ou avec encore d'autres
pays donc je suis absolument persuadée
que le président aborde la question des
droits humains parce que ce qu'il voit
un chef d'État c'est vrai qu'il a dit
quand on lui a posé la question
spontanément il faut pas politiser le
sport je pense que c'était assez pensé
on a des relations économiques
importantes avec le Qatar c'était une
réponse diplomatiquement correcte moi
vous savez j'ai appris vous aviez la
gentillesse de rappeler que j'avais
évolué au cours de mes expériences
gouvernementales quand je suis arrivé en
2017 moi je pensais comme beaucoup de
Français que quand on veut défendre des
positions de la France faut être vocale
faut faire des tweets des discours des
tribus etc et j'ai appris en menant
moi-même la diplomatie féministe pour
Emmanuel Macron et pour la France qu'en
fait parfois la diplomatie on fait mieux
avancer les dossiers quand on est en
face à face plutôt qu'en revendiquant
ensuite ce qu'on s'est dit ou ce qu'on
va se dire au préalable donc je sais que
le président est fermé intransigeant sur
les droits humains sur les droits des
personnes LGBT plus sur les droits des
femmes et que c'est ce qu'ils défend on
ne doutez pas qu'il le disent les yeux
dans les yeux aux autorités catharites
quand il ira il faut qu'il le fassent
compte tenu de des débats que vous
portez
la République ce qui doit faire mais
pour l'avoir accompagné à plusieurs
déplacements diplomatiques je suis
convaincu qu'il porte cette question des
droits humains en tête à tête dès qu'il
voit un chef d'État vous ne serez pas le
Laurent Fabius de François Mitterrand
qui vous rappeler avait dit en 1900 je
crois 84 je suis troublé quand François
Mitterrand avait reçu le président en
polonaise dans les skis non c'est plus
c'est pas ça vous n'êtes pas troubler
vous faites confiance à Emmanuel Macron
un dernier mot
ça vous fait dire personnellement encore
une fois ce qui se passe au Qatar pour
les homosexuels c'est un scandale absolu
ben moi vous savez je me réjouis du fait
qu'on est nommé très récemment une
nouvelle fonction d'ambassadeurs LGBT
plus c'est Jean-Marc Berton mon ancien
directeur de cabinet qui a un diplomate
reconnu qui a été nommé par le Président
de la République et sa mission c'est
justement de porter la dépénalisation de
l'homosexualité partout dans le monde
donc dans tous les pays du monde sans
aucune exception ni exclusion Brigitte
boucher tam-trans sont en face bonsoir
mesdames Brigitte boucher c'est vous qui
commencez par un sujet chaud oui le
sujet des retraites Elisabeth borne vise
toujours un départ à la retraite à 65
ans elle a indiqué dans une interview la
semaine dernière au Parisien pourquoi
braquer d'emblée les syndicats alors que
vous savez pertinemment qu'ils sont
contre ce décalage de l'âge de départ à
la retraite d'abord moi j'observe que il
y a une forme de consensus aujourd'hui
dans le champ politique on va dire dans
le pôle central du champ politique dans
le camp républicain on va dire si
j'avais pas tellement cette expression
mais on comprend en dehors des extrêmes
sur la nécessité de mener une réforme du
système des et moi j'étais très sensible
dans la dernière interview de la
première ministre Elisabeth borne au
fait qu'elles disent je veux sauver le
système de retraite par répartition et
moi c'est ça aussi qui me tient à cœur
c'est faire en sorte qu'on sauve notre
système par répartition avec une
solidarité entre les générations et
c'est ce système qui est en péril le
rapport du corps le dit et au-delà de ça
je veux souligner que dans le système
actuel des retraites c'est un système
profondément inégalitaire vous avez
encore des personnes et notamment des
femmes qui ont eu des carrières hachées
mais qui ont travaillé pendant une
grande partie de leur vie qui se
retrouve à l'âge de la retraite sous le
seuil de pauvre
républicain le Parti socialiste par
exemple les écologistes la nuque bon ça
vous le Cassez peut-être dans des
extrêmes en tout cas le PS et les Verts
ne veulent pas se décalage de l'âge de
départ plus de 70% des Français ils sont
aussi opposés Laurent Berger dit qu'il
n'y a aucune avancée sociale dans les
négociations qu'il mène est-ce que vous
avez pas raison un peu contre tout le
monde je dis à l'ensemble de ces
personnes qu'elle fasse des propositions
vous savez la question du système des
retraites elle est extrêmement délicate
elle n'est pas que technique elle est
aussi sociale et moi je l'avais porté à
l'époque d'Édouard Philippe où j'étais
déjà rattaché au Premier ministre et
avec Edouard Philippe on avait porté le
fait qu'on a besoin d'avoir un minimum
de retraite aujourd'hui Elisabelle borne
dit que pour elle ce serait 1200 euros
le minimum du montant de retrait c'est
quand même au-delà de ce que nous
portions à l'époque il y a eu un peu
d'inflation entre temps exactement c'est
la raison pour laquelle ce cette
proposition a été réhaussée mais il y a
du dialogue social il y a des gens
encore avec les syndicats parce que eux
aujourd'hui sont la preuve opposés à la
proposition de loi n'est pas ficelée
elle n'est pas déposée devant le Conseil
d'État ni présenté en Conseil des
ministres ça veut dire que
non
dans ces cas-là il faut faire des
propositions si la question ce n'est pas
l'âge et si des syndicats disent nous là
je ne veux pas y toucher il faut qu'il
fasse des propositions pour nous dire
comment on arrive à un système à
l'équilibre sans toucher à la question
de la question de la durée du travail
président de la République l'a déjà
évoqué
des Virgin spéciaux on l'a évoqué aussi
et puis moi je vous dis ça me tient à
coeur le fait de dire que on peut pas
rester dans ce système qui pénalise
aujourd'hui notamment des femmes et
qu'il aimait dans des situations
terribles à l'âge adulte le président
pardon il borde pas mal quand même la
négociation puisque il dit ok faites vos
propositions mais on ne touche pas au
montant des pensions et on ne touche pas
non plus au cotisation on les alourdit
pas donc si vous voulez ça fait pas
d'une alternative mais c'est très
important là je légale pour arriver au
même résultat sa campagne présidentielle
le présent a dit qu'il souhaitait porter
une réforme de retraite il a été élu il
met aujourd'hui en neuf son programme
reprocher au président de la République
de tenir les engagements qu'il a pris
pendant sa campagne et une réaction sur
la proposition du Sénat qui a fait voter
d'ailleurs un amendement au PLFSS qui
n'est budget de la Sécurité sociale qui
n'a pas été retenue mais c'était un âge
légal à 64 ans avec une hausse de
cotisation est-ce que ce mélange là il
peut être accepté à votre avis par le
chef de l'État par le gouvernement à mon
sens on est en dehors du cadre qui avait
a été posée mais encore une fois le
dernier mot revend au parlementaire
voilà je crois que c'est votre téléphone
m'excuser c'est pas une urgence
je vous prie de m'excuser je disais que
le dernier mot revient au parlementaire
dans tous les cas et donc il y aura un
débat parlementaire au-delà de la
concertation sociale avec les syndicats
et les représentants du patronum donc
voilà les parlementaires feront des
propositions c'est bien normal c'est le
rôle et nous verrons ce qui est voté la
ministre doit dévoiler ses arbitrages la
deuxième semaine de décembre est-ce
qu'il faut s'attendre à un Noël de grève
comme on en avait eu on se rappelle en
2019 déjà sur les retraites et ça avait
beaucoup paralysé la France je le
souhaite pas évidemment je pense qu'on
traverse des temps qui sont difficiles
vous avez parlé de l'inflation de la
guerre en Ukraine la pandémie qui
circule de nouveau des perspectives
difficiles je pense que les Français ont
besoin de se retrouver en famille et
notamment de pouvoir aller voir les plus
anciens les enfants et de profiter des
fêtes de famille qu'est-ce que vous
dites justement au syndicat qui annonce
déjà pour Laurent Berger une riposte
totale et il n'est pas levé d'abord moi
je suis très respectueuse du droit
greffe c'est un droit constitutionnel
donc le droit de grève ne je le remets
absolument pas en question ceci étant je
suis toujours un peu circonspect quand
on parle de grève par anticipation ou
qu'on prévient qu'on fera grève si
d'aventure il se passait quelque chose
dans l'avenir donc moi je j'invite
chacun au dialogue social et à la vertu
du dialogue social plutôt qu'à prévenir
d'emblée que on fera grève si on obtient
pas ce qu'on veut qu'elle regarde vous
portez sur le mouvement qui a eu le
week-end dernier cette grande entreprise
comme la SNCF qui a donc pénalisé
beaucoup de Français un peu sans
prévenir le week-end dernier oui bien
sûr ben c'est difficile il y a des gens
qui ont pas pu se retrouver on a tous
autour de nous des gens qui avaient
prévu de se retrouver en famille et qui
n'ont pas pu le faire c'est extrêmement
difficile alors j'ai conscience d'envie
des transports Clément bonne qu'un homme
de dialogue et qui est tâche de trouver
des solutions les plus concrètes et les
plus pragmatiques dans les meilleurs
délais possibles pour faire en sorte
qu'on sorte de ce que ça vous fera pas
qu'une grande entreprises que la SNCF
des plus grandes entreprises françaises
ça ne vous fera pas que ça se passe
comme ça une presque une grève ou
débottée qui pénalise au dernier moment
des Français
moi je dirais pas que c'est une question
de dysfonctionnement je vous l'ai dit le
droit de grève pour moi c'est un droit
constitutionnel donc on fasse grève pour
avoir des pour le porter vous ne le
condamnez pas vous ne le condamnez pas
que c'est moi je souhaite pas être dans
un pays où les membres du gouvernement
condamne la grève il s'agit pas de
condamner la grève il s'agit de dire si
on est d'accord ou pas d'accord sur les
questions de fond d'appeler au dialogue
d'écouter d'entendre mais je vous l'ai
dit je suis aussi profondément gênée par
le dévoiement du droit de grève et par
le fait de prévenir par anticipation ce
sera des grèves
s'il y avait tout ce mouvement
si j'ai pas ce que je veux je fais grève
non mais ça ça s'appelle du chantage en
fait de dire si la négociation n'aboutit
pas à ce que moi je veux je ferai c'est
pas une négociation dans ces cas-là mais
vous vous attendez à des grèves qui
peuvent durer de 3 à 4 semaines semaine
voire plus le gouvernement est prêt à
tenir nous verrons moi je veux pas faire
dénoncer c'est-à-dire je veux pas
moi-même rentrer dans un rapport de
force et faire du chantage et dire on
s'aidera rien je veux pas voir les
choses comme ça et partir du principe le
dialogue échoura je vais partir du
principe le dialogue va réussir
Elisabeth borne c'est une femme de
dialogue la première mix tout son
parcours à montrer à quel moment
on dit déjà un peu le point d'arrivée
quoi les 60 ans
du droit de grève quand on pose déjà les
65 ans sur la table
la question c'est dire si demain je vous
appelle pour dire on va négocier d'un
sujet mais je vous préviens c'est la
négociation n'arrive pas à ce que je
veux bah voilà ce que je ferais de
manière hostile vis-à-vis de vous ben
c'est un dévoiement du principe de
principe de la grève c'est de prévenir
en posant effectivement ces exigences en
disant je ferais grève au cas où vous
fassiez telle réforme alors qu'on a pas
encore déposé de projets de loi là
dessus non je trouve ça surprenant en
revanche ce que je disais c'est
qu'Elisabeth borne elle a démontré dans
tout son parcours et dans tous les
ministères auxquels euh elle a eu des
responsabilités à quel point elle savait
justement mener le dialogue avancer sur
dialogue social elle a été au ministère
du Travail elle a porté des réformes
lourdes
du statut
exactement vous dites il faut dialoguer
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on exclut du coup
de passer par un 49-3 sur cette réforme
des retraites on dit on laisse le temps
au débat non mais là non plus je veux
pas faire ce que je dénonce c'est-à-dire
je veux pas aller au bout de la
discussion là la première mise vient
juste de poser les termes du débat de
réaffirmer sa volonté de mettre en
oeuvre le projet du président de la
République sur lequel je répète il a été
élu sur lequel une majorité de députés
ont été élus majorité relatives certes
mais majorité quand même et que le
président élu et la majorité élue sur ce
projet souhaite le mettre en oeuvre je
trouve ça très normal les Français nous
reprocheraient le contraire vous vous
avez pas effectivement la majorité ça
veut dire que vous espérez que la droite
de votre cette réforme alors la logique
mais relative et moi je souhaite qu'on
puisse trouver des points d'accord pas
uniquement avec la droite le Parti
socialiste c'est un grand parti du
gouvernement il y a pas si longtemps et
a eu amener des réformes ambitieuses
on peut faire la liste de toutes les
réformes du quinquennat de François
Hollande que la gauche considère
aujourd'hui comme plus vraiment de
gauche et je pense que les
parlementaires qui sont raisonnables et
attachés à l'équilibre des finances
publiques peuvent tout à fait nous
rejoindre sur ce sujet et l'idée d'un
référendum sur les retraites défendus
notamment par Fabien Roussel le
communisme ça ça aurait un intérêt c'est
un outil qui a la main du président de
la République donc après c'est à lui de
dire s'il souhaite à un moment de son
quinquennat faire un appel direct aux
Français sur ce sujet ou sur un autre et
pour vous ça aurait du sens une réforme
qui doit entrer en vigueur à l'été 2023
c'est pas un appel jour on se répond à
la question que vous me posez sur ce
sujet et là encore encore faut-il se
poser la question de ce qui serait
demandée aux Français parce qu'un
référendum ça dépend si la manière dont
la question est tournée est-ce que ce
serait sur l'âge est-ce que ce serait
sur la nécessité d'un principe d'une
réforme partagez vous l'idée qu'il
faille réformer les retraites ou est-ce
que 65 ans ça va pour vous ou pas c'est
moins c'est plus c'est rien ça peut être
un référendum à plusieurs questions à
l'heure actuelle ce n'est pas sur la
table un autre sujet de référendum là
proposition de loi de la France
insoumise qui est inscrit le droit à
l'IVG dans la Constitution donc elle a
été adoptée très largement à l'Assemblée
nationale maintenant elle arrive au
Sénat le Sénat qui a donc rejeté il y a
quelques semaines un texte qui voulait
peu ou la même chose qu'est-ce que vous
dites aujourd'hui au sénateur
[Musique]
également la prouver mais j'ai vu que
même Marine Le Pen disait qu'elle
souhaitait constitutionnaliser elle
l'ensemble de la loi veille donc en fait
aujourd'hui le consensus me semble-t-il
est assez large en France sur ce sujet
là la question c'est le comment on
l'écrit et qu'est-ce qu'on met
réellement dans ce qui s'oppose à ses
clairement au Sénat c'est Bruno
Retailleau le patron des sénateurs LR
qui est donc dans le duel final face à
Éric Ciotti du coup ça ça vous pousse
plutôt
que vous faites habilement le lien entre
les deux informations et que vous avez
raison de le faire peut-être Bruno
Retailleau est-il en train de cranter en
positionnement politique pour montrer
qu'il ave plus blanc que blanc et qu'il
est plus à droite que la droite de la
droite et que lui s'oppose à ses grands
projets qui quand même aujourd'hui il
faut qu'on s'ensuit vous savez moi
j'étais à qui elle brune Pivet la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale pour
l'inauguration du buste Simone Veil avec
la famille de Simone Weiss très
émouvante dans les jardins des quatre
colonnes de l'Assemblée nationale et
elle a rappelé à ce moment-là de même
que les fils de bonne veille que ces
grandes transformations de société qui
font en débat et qui clivent tant à
l'époque finissent paraître aujourd'hui
consensuel et je pense que aujourd'hui
personne à l'heure actuelle de sérieux
dans un parti de gouvernement en France
ne songe à remettre en question le droit
des femmes à avorter mais si vous me
permettez cette idée qui ne veut pas
remettre il dit que ce droit n'est pas
personnel
je pense qu'au-delà du symbole qui est
important on a aujourd'hui une question
de maillage territorial moi je suis
parisienne mais à Paris élu de Paris
mais j'ai été lu en sarth je suis
originaire de Corse je sais que tu as
des engagés exactement il y a des
endroits aujourd'hui en France où il est
très difficile d'avoir un rendez-vous
avec un gynécologue du coup c'est ça la
priorité
[Musique]
d'avoir un institutionnalisé non mais je
pense que c'est un très bon symbole mais
je pense que pour faciliter le
rendez-vous concret c'est la même chose
sur l'allongement des délais pourquoi
est-ce que les parlementaires ont
souhaité allonger les délais pour dire
que c'est heureux de d'avoir têtard ou
que les femmes s'aperçoivent très tard
dans leur ma éviter qu'elles sont
enceintes c'est pas le cas dans
l'immense majorité on s'en aperçoit au
début de la grossesse mais on tarde à
trouver un rendez-vous chez un
gynécologue c'est ça pour moi le noeud
et c'est ce sur quoi le ministre de la
Santé François Braun travail j'étais
avec lui au CNR santé en Sarthe
justement pour faire en sorte que la
désertification médicale ou les
problèmes de délai médicaux à Paris on
n'a pas désertification médicale par
exemple mais c'est très long pour avoir
un rendez-vous si vous voulez atteindre
Emmanuel Macron a été interrogé il a
donné une interview Parisien ce week-end
et il a été interrogé sur l'affaire
cadenas il dit qu'il n'est pas là pour
faire la police de la démocratie et vous
en pensez quoi c'est présent la
République c'est garant des institutions
donc je trouve sa réponse extrêmement
compréhensible moi j'ai toujours dit
qu'en tant que mini je n'appelle pas à
la démission d'un parlementaire je suis
respectueuse de la séparation des
pouvoirs j'incarne le pouvoir exécutif
un régime dans lequel le pouvoir
exécutif choisit les représentants et
lui par le peuple n'est pas un régime
démocratique je suis attachée au
principe de démocratie je m'appelle donc
pas à la démission d'un député
non je dis que ma position aujourd'hui
demande du gouvernance je suis pas
Marlène Schiappa activiste ou une
personne que vous interrogez dans un
micro-trottoir je représente l'exécutif
l'exécutif n'a pas à demander la
démission d'un parlement pour autant à
mon avis pour autant évidemment je suis
scandalisée par les propos d'abord les
faits et les actes qu'Adrien catenens à
avouer tout innocent qu'il fut aux yeux
de la loi ont eu égard à la présomption
d'innocence et je suis choquée aussi par
les propos qui ont été tenus par tous
les ténors de LFI qui ont fait le défilé
des plateaux Télévisions pour minimiser
et pour dire que si c'était une gifle
isolée c'était pas grave moi je ne dis
pas cela je dis que une gifle surtout
quand elle est avouée et bien c'est un
fait grave de violence conjugales on a
passé 6 ans à dire après le Grenelle des
violences conjugales aux femmes une gif
c'est grave il faut partir dès la
première gifle etc c'est trop même elle
qui en appelle quand même à la nuance et
à la gradation des faits on ne peut pas
cons gifle c'est la même chose que des
violences conjugales beaucoup plus
graves est-ce que vous entendez ça une
gifle ça fait partie des violences
conjugales mais bien sûr qu'il y a une
gradation mais dans le enfin dans toutes
nos lois il y a dégradations le Code
civil le code pénal notre droit est
fondé sur la proportion à la
proportionnalité des peines évidemment
vous n'êtes pas condamné de la même
chose
par exemple si vous avez du sel c'est
pas la même chose que non c'est pas ça
qui l'a dit il est allé beaucoup plus
loin en disant c'est un fait violent
mais ce n'est pas un homme violent en
disant c'est une gifle mais ce n'est pas
grave et pardon dans le champ lexical
utilisé par la France insoumise
Clémentine Autain encore récemment a dit
les hommes violents se sont aussi nos
maris nos amis nos camarades et donc
avant de les punir il faut les
accompagner etc un discours en totale
incohérence avec tout ce que a toujours
dit la France insoumise qui s'est quand
même assis sur la présomption
d'innocence dès lors que des accusations
de cet ordre là concernaient des
personnes dans des camps opposés donc
moi j'appelle au respect de la
séparation des pouvoirs au respect de la
justice c'est à la justice aujourd'hui
de dire s'il adrien catenens est aux
yeux de la justice et du droit coupable
ou innocent j'appelle aussi à la décence
et au respect des victimes on peut pas
dire que l'écoute se soient libérés et
quand une femme va déposer une main
courante la balayée d'un revers de main
et dire comme Jean-Luc Mélenchon que
c'est Adrien catenin c'est la victime
puisqu'il reçoit des gifles politiques
c'est indécent une dernière question sur
les violences intrafamiliales encore
l'Assemblée nationale a voté la semaine
dernière contre la vie du gouvernement
et contre la majorité une proposition de
loi d'Aurélien Pradier pour une
juridiction spécialisée contre les
violences intrafamilales pourquoi cette
opposition alors que de la majorité
alors que vous travaillez sur ce sujet
et que c'est une des pistes d'évolution
est-ce que c'est pas une opposition de
principe non d'abord moi si vous voulez
je vais faire un rapprochement avec la
question de l'accès à l'IVG c'est la
fausse bonne idée pour moi c'est à dire
que dans il faut regarder si on veut
regarder ce qui a fait l'Espagne en fait
l'Espagne a commencé en fonction en
Espagne oui à qui dites-vous c'est moi
qui ai commencé à dire avec le Grenelle
des violences social regardez ce que
fait l'Espagne etc l'Espagne a commencé
en 2004 et elle a pas juste fait une
proposition de loi pour dire on va faire
des juges spécialisés ils se sont
organisés là aussi pour qu'il y a un
maillage territorial et je vous rappelle
que l'Espagne ne fonctionne pas comme la
France n'est pas un pays centralisé
comme les le fonctionnement de la France
et de la justice française si demain
vous avez des tribunaux spécialisés
aujourd'hui la justice n'est pas en
mesure à partir du moment où cette loi
serait mise en oeuvre de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait un tribunal par département
par circonscription ça veut dire que
vous ne serez pas jugé de la même
manière selon vous habitez encore à
Marseille dans les Alpes-Maritimes ou à
côté de lime et l'affaire sera jugée
loin
vous n'êtes donc pas jugé de la même
manière c'est extrêmement différent
c'est une inégalité d'accès à la justice
et donc moi je ne dis pas non au
tribunaux spécialisé je pense que c'est
un sujet important qui se regarde et que
le Garde des Sceaux est en train
d'étudier pour voir si oui ou non ça
apporterait un bénéfice et moi ce que je
pense je vais vous dire c'est qu'il faut
former tous les magistrats et toute la
chaîne de réussissent à la question des
violences conjugales pour ne plus
entendre il faut une juridiction
spécialisée il faut pas des spécialistes
dans une juridiction classique non mais
il faut pour moi que tous les magistrats
soient formés à ces sujets là
aujourd'hui un magistrat il est formé au
droit civils quel que soit par ailleurs
la juridiction dans laquelle il évolue
donc c'est fondamental que les avocats
les magistrats comprennent cela on a
fait voter 5 lois en 5 ans pour
améliorer les droits des femmes il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'amélioration reste
beaucoup à faire il reste beaucoup
beaucoup
2021 non ils ont d'abord augmenté
ensuite ils ont baissé en 2021 par
rapport à 2020 il y a une diminution il
y a une augmentation eu égard au fait de
la baisse du covid si vous prenez les
chiffres de féminicides depuis 2012 vous
avez hélas tous les ans une tranche qui
est similaire et je le déplore parce
qu'on n'arrive pas encore à les faire
baisser dans la durée mais on a réussi à
les faire baisser pendant le covid
pourquoi pas parce que les portes
étaient fermées mais parce que toute la
société s'est mobilisée et qu'on pouvait
déposer plainte et alerter des associés
pour conclure centre commerciaux merci
beaucoup brigitte est en train de nuit
dans quelques minutes je reviendrai sur
le dossier bénévolat parce qu'on voit
que évidemment n'ont pas les vocations
mais les bonnes volontés sont en baisse
on rejoint tout de suite Vincent roux
merci beaucoup Roger têtard à la semaine
prochaine Vincent roux bonjour à vous
Vincent en direct du Figaro life vous
avez regardé les centres d'intérêt des
lecteurs du Figaro et alors les pannes
de courant franchement c'est au top je
voulais dire des préoccupations pourquoi
c'est même au top des préoccupations des
Français est-ce que vous êtes sereine
bonsoir Marlène Schiappa est-ce que vous
êtes sereine par rapport à cette
situation est-ce que vous dites comme le
président pas de panique
mais je dis évidemment qu'il faut qu'on
réussisse à éviter les mouvements de
panique mais je le dis pourquoi je dis
parce que le gouvernement a un plan un
plan qui a été présenté construit avec
les collectivités avec l'ensemble des
partenaires avec les entreprises pour
réussir à diminuer notre consommation
d'électricité de moins 10% et je vais
vous dire j'ai envie toutes les
personnes qui regardent aujourd'hui
cette émission à installer sur leur
téléphone le dispositif Ecowatt c'est la
météo de l'électricité et ça vous permet
justement pardon vous voulez intervenir
oui je veux intervenir parce que il y a
une rhétorique du gouvernement et
notamment Olivier vivant la semaine
dernière qui vise à donner à toujours
des conseils pratiques mais on voit dans
le sondage que nous avons fait pour
cODEXA a fait pour le figa relation
dernière que
57% des Français n'en peuvent plus de
cette rhétorique et il pense que c'est
d'abord et avant tout à l'état de les
protéger par rapport
dans cette situation non mais ça je le
comprends moi si vous voulez j'entends y
compris les critiques en disant c'est
l'état nounou on nous a appris à nous
laver les mains pendant le covid
maintenant nous apprend à éteindre la
lumière quand on quitte une pièce je
comprends tout à fait que ça puisse
agacer je suis pas du tout en train de
de défendre cela en revanche ce que je
défends c'est que on a ici un enjeu
collectif et si chacun d'entre nous est
attentif sur les heures de tension rouge
à diminuer sa consommation d'électricité
on arrivera à passer ce cap sans aucune
coupure d'électricité donc c'est
vraiment un enjeu collectif mais du coup
Emmanuel Macron dit où vous êtes sage où
vous faites qu'on vous demande où ça
marchera pas il y a une forme de
culpabilisation quand même non je dois
responsabilité qui repose sur les
Français et leur discipline il y a une
responsabilité collective parce que
Français sur 10 disent que c'est à
l'État
que fait l'état dès le 14 juillet le
présent de la République a anticipé
cette question dans son interview
souvenez-vous il a parlé de ce sujet en
disant qu'on pouvait passer l'hiver
ensemble si on arrivait à diminuer 10%
notre consommation et l'idée c'est de
demander des plus gros efforts au plus
gros et donc les grandes entreprises les
administrations bien sûr on attend de
leur part des efforts plus importants
mais quand il y a des heures de tension
d'électricité et bien on réussira si
chacun d'entre nous surveille sa
consommation d'électricité c'est un fait
scientifique on peut pas dire ce serait
pas responsable de dire aux gens les
sons les lumières consommons comme comme
chacun le souhaite et puis peu importe
et adjen que pourra sur les coupures au
contraire on veut anticiper pour éviter
ces coupures merci Vincent je sens que
vous êtes frustré vous auriez voulu
poursuivre mais on vous retrouve tout à
l'heure Vincent bonjour Yves triart
directement adjoint de la rédaction du
client c'est à VOUS bonjour hier soir
hier midi plus précisément le l'ancien
président de la République Nicolas
Sarkozy était du Conseil représentatif
des institutions juives de France et il
a
répété en allant d'ailleurs un peu
au-delà de ce qu'il avait dit jusqu'à
présent en disant il faut qu'il y ait un
accord entre les républicains et le
pouvoir exécutif actuel est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça
d'abord moi j'écoute ce que dit le
président Sarkozy et il y a pas de temps
d'anciens présidents de la République
qui ont une parole intéressante et au
service de l'intérêt général dans les
temps qui courent donc j'écoute ce qu'il
dit quand il s'exprime ensuite moi je ne
faisais pas de LR donc si vous voulez ce
qui me préoccupe ce n'est pas l'avenir
du groupe politique les républicains qui
a eu une candidature
le groupe les républicains enfin le
parti les républicains a quand même une
candidate qui a fait un score moindre à
la campagne à l'élection pardon
présidentielle
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale nous
avons une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale une majorité relative c'est
une majorité quand même c'est pas une
minorité
l'expression
de faire passer vos textes c'est d'avoir
des majorités de projets pour l'instant
plusieurs ministres qui ont eu à
défendre des lois au Parlement réussi à
avoir des majorités de projets
maintenant si des parlementaires LR
souhaite rejoindre la majorité ou
travailler avec nous sur certains
projets on y est bien évidemment ouvert
je crois par exemple un parlementaire
extrêmement brillant et engagé sur Créer
un sujet qui fut pécré-ci c'était bien
acquitter le groupe LR pour rejoindre
naissance comme constance le grip par
exemple et comme d'autres comme Eric
verte comme dans la société alerte pour
venir non mais je dis que ça m'a fait
votre majorité un peu trop à droite
c'est ça non mais il s'agit ce sera à
Stéphane séjourner de répondre sur les
accords de partie puisque c'est une
secrétaire général du parti Renaissance
nous avons d'ailleurs accueilli cette
semaine Renault Muselier qui vient lui
aussi de alerte vous voyez tous les
talents de LR sont en train de venir
chez Renaissance et qui est maintenant
membre du bureau exécutif président de
région sud et soutient d'Emmanuel Macron
le président Sarkozy est allé au-delà
parce qu'il est allé chercher une
citation du président Pompidou en disant
que c'était au plus fort de tendre la
main au plus faible le président
Pompidou c'est peut-être une phrase
apocryphe j'en sais rien mais aurait dit
ça quand on est président ou dans la
main et ben est-ce que vous encouragez
votre président de la République a
tendre la main aux députés des
républicains mais tendre la main aux
autres c'est tout l'ADN politique du
président Emmanuel Macron il s'est
engagé en 2017 sur le dépassement des
clivages et il a mis autour de la table
du Conseil des ministres Bruno Le Maire
Gérald Darmanin Marlène Schiappa et
maintenant dans son nouveau gouvernement
Elisabeth borne Olivier Dussac il a
toujours et sans cesse élargi sa
majorité
comme vous regardez les LR là parce
qu'il y a une prime il y a pas une
primaire il y a une élection président
interne à ce parti est-ce que on les
écoutant en écoutant cette campagne vous
estimez qui vraiment il penche trop à
droite
partie de droite défendre des idées de
droite ça me choque pas pardon d'être
trop ouverte à la démocratie
un peu triste pour la démocratie quand
des parties qui ont été des grands
partis de gouvernement sont finalement
un peu à la ramasse comme c'est le cas
du Parti socialiste qui aujourd'hui à la
remorque de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui ne
contribue plus au débat d'idées donc
nous verrons il y a un processus interne
à Herge pas vocation à intervenir et
être l'arbitre des élégances entre
monsieur rotaïo et Monsieur Ciotti ils
sont chacun élus donc ce sera à leur
militant de les départager alors vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure vous êtes
Corse
un détour
et Paris alors Paris ça vous intéresse
beaucoup on le sait vous habitez Paris
vous vous êtes présenté à Paris et vous
avez une idée c'est de réformer
l'élection du maire de Paris qui est une
élection au suffrage universel certes
mais indirecte et vous vous dites non
non il faut que l'élection du maire ou
de la mère de Paris se fasse au suffrage
universel direct c'est-à-dire que la
population Élise son maire quel est
l'avenir de cette forte ambition écoutez
d'abord moi merci de le rappeler moi je
suis parisienne je suis allé dans le 13e
arrondissement de Paris j'ai grandi dans
une cité à Belleville ensuite port de
vent je passais mon bac dans le 16e je
suis mariée j'ai eu mes enfants etc donc
oui je suis parisienne et élue de Paris
aujourd'hui et effectivement moi je
considère que les Parisiens ont le droit
de choisir leur mère aujourd'hui on est
dans une situation très paradoxale à
Paris où nous avons une mère de Paris
élue par le jeu des élections au
suffrage indirect par les conseillers de
Paris et par le jeu des arrondissements
c'est pour ça qu'il pourrait y avoir une
un projet PLM Paris Lyon Marseille de
modifications du scrutin dans lequel on
considère que dans les grandes villes
aussi on a le droit de choisir son maire
moi je trouve que les Parisiens ont
droit de choisir leur mère Gérald
Darmanin le ministre de l'Intérieur en
charge des élections cela fait partie
des pistes qu'il étudient c'est pas la
seule mais c'est une des pistes qu'il
étudie sur l'évolution du mode de
scrutin j'ai eu à constater que c'était
une demande aussi qui émanait d'élus là
de tout bord politique y compris LR
qu'on évoquait à l'instant mais aussi de
sénateur monsieur Charron et d'autres
donc je pense que ça peut sérieusement
faire partie des pistes
non si la majorité est sûre d'elle-même
elle doit pouvoir se confronter au
suffrage universel des électeurs en
étant sereine pourquoi est-elle fébrile
comme ça à l'idée de se confronter aux
autres
c'est une réforme portée par Monsieur
Darmanin alors c'est pas une annonce que
je vous fais je vous dis c'est mon
souhait ainsi que celui d'autres élus
c'est d'ailleurs Sylvain Maillard qui
est candidat à la présidence absolument
qui est candidat à la présidence de la
fédération Renaissance à Paris excellent
député que je soutiens Sylvain Maillard
donc qui porte et qui est figure de
proue de ce projet que je soutiens et le
ministre de l'intérieur est en train de
l'étudier comme d'autres projets à la
demande des élus de Paris
[Musique]
sur ce projet en tant que tel donc je
peux pas donner de calendrier avant
l'arbitrage il appartiendra au ministre
de l'Intérieur de dire si ça fait partie
des pistes qu'il souhaite retenir bien
sûr sur la base de la consultation des
élus les premiers concernés alors il y
aura des élections municipales à Paris
en 2026
et
si vous me permettez il y a du monde
wALCOM
du monde sur la corde
et alors on sait qu'il y en a deux dans
votre formation politique et bien qui
se verrait bien la maire de Paris en
tous les cas qui se dispute la
candidature à la candidature c'est d'un
d'une part Gabriel Attal qui est au
gouvernement et d'autre part
Clément bon qui est aussi au
gouvernement et ils sont eu des mots pas
très agréables envers l'autre un peu
contradictoire comme vous voyez les
choses non mais d'abord moi je n'ai
entendu ni l'un ni l'autre exprimé de
candidature à la candidature je pense
qu'il est très tôt je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est très soudés on a
beaucoup de travail autour d'un
collectif il y a Gabriel Attal bien sûr
qui a beaucoup de talents ministres des
comptes publics Clément bonne également
vous avez des élus de Paris j'ai cité
Sylvain Maillard mais on peut mentionner
aussi David Amiel Astrid panossurance
Stanislas Guerini le mini il faut mettre
Paris sous tutelle et Gabriel Attal dit
non pas du tout parce que la dette de
Paris n'arrête pas de s'envoler non mais
moi je crois qu'on gagne toujours à
l'unité vous savez mais j'ai vécu les
élections municipales les précédentes
qui ont été extrêmement compliquées pour
la majorité ce genre de féminisme à
Paris et donc moi je suis très attachée
à l'unité moi je souhaite qu'on soit uni
qu'on travaille sur cette réforme du
mode de scrutin qu'on s'organise à Paris
autour du futur président de la
fédération et puis ensuite qu'on
travaille sur un projet avec un candidat
et avec même 17 candidats celui-là il y
a de la place pour tout le monde
aujourd'hui l'élection à Paris si ça
reste sur ce mode de scrutin et si les
arrondissements restent comme tel ça
veut dire vous devez avoir 17 maires
d'arrondissement tête de liste chacun
avec une liste il faut trouver du monde
c'est une équipe qui doit être soudée
dernière on a besoin toutes les énergies
vous vous maire de Paris vous êtes
envisageable
je sais qu'on prête beaucoup d'ambition
beaucoup plus que ce que je n'en ai
réellement moi ma vraie ambition c'est
de rentrer à l'heure tout à l'heure
vérifier et devoirs de mes filles pour
tout vous dire mais chacun son ambition
elle est légitime comme une autre ce que
vous dites en tout cas aux candidats
c'est très clair de votre majorité c'est
un peu de patience ce serait un petit
peu prématuré de manifester son ambition
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié et beaucoup de
respect pour aussi leur trajectoire
politique mais c'est parce qu'on dit
d'ailleurs pour s'exprimer et voilà et
c'est important qu'on reste unis tous
ensemble on voit là que ça ne dépasse
pas trop les égaux merci beaucoup
c'est aujourd'hui la Journée mondiale du
bénévolat Marlène Chapa et c'est vrai
qu'on observe je le disais tout à
l'heure une petite crise 15 % de
candidature en moins de bénévolat est-ce
que c'est une sonnette d'alarme et
pourquoi vous savez nous on a commandé
une étude donc qui est parue aujourd'hui
à Paris interactif justement sur le
panorama du rapport des Français avec
l'engagement associatif et avec le
bénévolat justement pour battre en bref
un certain nombre d'idées reçues
notamment c'est vrai que pendant le
covid il y a des personnes qui du coup
notamment des personnes d'incertennage
ou fragiles en termes de santé qui ne
sont plus ressortis qui ne sont plus
retournés dans les associations
néanmoins on travaille pour attirer de
nouveaux bénévoles ce matin nous avions
une étape du Tour de France du bénévolat
sur la région Île-de-France dans mon
ministère 80 bénévoles qui font des
ateliers d'idées pour réfléchir à la
meilleure manière d'attirer des
bénévoles et moi j'ai une idée par
rapport à ça c'est la simplification
administrative j'adore la France mais on
est vraiment le pays de la paperasse il
y a des papiers ça fait 30 ans qu'on
entend ça marine je sais pas alors les
promesses en la matière si vous voulez
excusez-moi l'expression on en a un peu
souper qu'est-ce que vous faites
concrètement
écoutez concrètement on passe à un
guichet unique concrètement on passe à
de la dématérialisation vous voyez qu'il
y a des propositions extrêmement
concrètes que nous allons mettre en
oeuvre dans l'année un guichet unique
pour les subventions c'est beaucoup de
temps gagné vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure ça fait 6 ans que je suis au
gouvernement ça fait 6 ans que je vois
des mêmes associations qui tous les ans
doivent réexpliquer qui elles sont ce
qu'elles font pourquoi elles ont besoin
de fonds etc on gagnerait un guichet
unique une explication principe du dites
le nous une fois et à des conventions
d'objectifs plus réanuels plutôt que des
appels à projets qui leur permettent
d'être sécurisé dans leur budget ça
c'est une réforme que vous êtes en train
de mettre en place la simplification
pour les associations vous avez été en
charge de la citoyenneté cette crise
quand même elle dit quoi est-ce qu'elle
vous inquiète c'est conjoncturel ou
est-ce que c'est structurel moi je vois
des Français très engagés dans l'étude
que je vous parle dont je vous parlais
qu'on a publié aujourd'hui près d'un
Français sur deux se déclarent engagés
dans une association plus d'un Français
sur tissu dans ton absolument besoin
absolument moi j'ai récompensé à la
citoyenneté les prodiges de la
République c'est jeune qui se sont
engagés bénévolement pendant le covid au
service des autres faire des courses
pour des personnes plus âgées faire de
l'aide aux devoirs des Français
solidaires et généreux on envoie tous
les jours et c'est ça la réalité de ce
pays le guichet unique c'est pour quand
je pense qu'on est en train d'y
travailler nous dans les mois qui
viennent d'ici la fin 2023 oui cours en
2023 d'accord pour l'établissement d'une
association et son renouvellement de
demande de subvention et puis qu'elle ne
doivent pas déposer des dossiers dans 4
ministères quand elle fait des violences
qu'on la prévention face aux violences
conjugales par exemple et qu'elle émarge
au sport la prévention de la délinquance
à l'égalité voilà un dossier un papier
je vous le donne et c'est géré on attend
les précisions merci beaucoup sur cette
question en face de vous Arthur de la
porte bonsoir merci d'avoir rejoint vous
êtes députés socialiste membre de la
commission des affaires sociales élues
du Calvados et vous êtes le bienvenu
merci à tous les deux d'avoir accepté le
débat c'est la question de la jeunesse
et la précarité sur laquelle vous voulez
d'abord interpeller la ministre malade
bonsoir à vous bonsoir
les prodiges de la République et je sais
que vous avez salué sur votre précédente
mandat certains jeunes qui sont engagés
dans l'aide alimentaire pour les
étudiants qui ont souffert notamment de
la crise du covid mais saluer
l'engagement des jeunes ce qui est bien
ce n'est pas suffisant parce que ce
qu'il faut c'est traiter le problème à
la racine et aujourd'hui on voit bien
que un jeune sur deux un étudiant sur
deux n'arrive pas à manger à sa fin et à
subvenir à ses besoins alimentaires donc
ma question est finalement assez simple
pourquoi être revenu en arrière sur le
ticket à 1 euro pour tous les étudiants
non mais plusieurs choses d'abord sur le
repas en euros pour les étudiants on
n'est pas revenu en arrière il est
toujours en vigueur c'est une engagement
des étudiants non mais c'est un
engagement d'Emmanuel Macron pour faire
en sorte
je vais reprendre les choses dans
l'ordre d'abord sur les médailles sur ce
que vous disiez sur les médailles c'est
évidemment pas le résumé de la politique
publique menée par le gouvernement en
direction des jeunes je pense que c'est
fondamental d'avoir cette reconnaissance
pour ce justement qui n'en demande pas
et de venir les décorer et vous auriez
vu les jeunes qui sont venus au
ministère de l'Intérieur pour la
première fois de leur vie voilà donc je
remercie de le salut c'est pas la seule
chose que nous faisons vous savez moi
j'étais avec la première ministre il y a
encore deux ou trois semaines de cela
auprès des banques alimentaires
justement elle a développé un fond de 60
millions d'euros pour soutenir les
banques alimentaires et pour faire en
sorte que les étudiants les plus
précaires puissent avoir accès à une
alimentation de qualité auprès des
banques alimentaires aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas une jeunesse en France il y a des
jeunes qui sont dans la situation que
vous décrivez je vous rejoins
parfaitement qui sont dans une situation
de précarité qui n'ont pas de quoi se
nourrir ce qui ne peuvent pas accumuler
le travail et leurs études et on a
besoin d'être auprès de c'est ce que
nous faisons avec les avec le
plafonnement des loyers pour eux avec
les banques
pourquoi
un euro pour tous les étudiants
cher Monsieur le Député je vous dis
qu'il n'y a pas une jeunesse en France
il y a effectivement une jeunesse qui
traverse des difficultés qui est dans
une situation précaire et c'est pour
cette jeunesse que nous faisons le
plafonnement des loyers les aides avec
les CROUS les bourses augmentaient la
question c'est fond de 60 millions
d'euros pour les banques alimentaires
auprès desquelles ils peuvent se nourrir
vous avez aussi des étudiants qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas dans le besoin
qui ont soit suffisamment d'argent
eux-mêmes soit leurs parents et qui
n'ont pas besoin aujourd'hui de
bénéficier de ces aides et donc moi je
veux aider les plus pauvres et ceux qui
ont moins et c'est ça pour moi une
politique sociale c'est aider ceux qui
sont moins ceux qui sont plus
suffisamment bourse aujourd'hui et c'est
pour ça si on n'a pas assez on les
augmente
en France mais vous me dites 80% des
gens qui n'ont pas de bourse en France
alors qu'on ne vous disais qu'il y avait
la moitié des jeunes qui n'arrivaient
pas à manger
en fait je vous demande juste de
répondre à des questions sur la
précarité de la jeunesse en France le
député
des questions donc je suis là pour vous
poser des questions je peux apporter des
éléments de demande des éléments débat
mais en fait c'est pas vous qui
choisissez
un euro alors attendez pas tous les deux
en même temps
à quelle question n'a pas répondu un
minimum
est-ce que vous savez qu'il y a des
étudiants qui sont comme si je sortais
donc c'est où et que je c'est ce que
vous avez dit on peut faire un magnéto
et Madame de la première c'est la
question que vous venez de me poser donc
moi je ne sais vous avez l'un des
licatesse de me dire que mon parcours ne
vous intéresse pas moi je me permets de
vous répondre en vous disant que vous ne
savez pas par quoi je suis passé étant
jeune ou étant étudiante et les
questions que vous me posez non
seulement je les connais mais je les ai
vécu moi j'ai eu l'électricité coupée
quand j'étais jeune j'ai des difficultés
terribles financières quand j'étais
jeune justement parce que j'avais pas de
bourse on disait que mes parents
n'avaient qu'à m'aider parce qu'il y
avait des dysfonctionnements dans le
système qui font que je ne pouvais pas
mener à terme vos études et bien que
faisons-nous nous faisons en sorte que
ces jeunes ils puissent se loger d'abord
avec le plafonnement justement des lois
ne faites pas non c'est vrai c'est une
mesure pourquoi
l'inflation par contre vous avez permis
la revalorisation des loyers sur un
autre sujet quand vous voyez que je vous
ai apporté des réponses ça vous plaît
pas donc vous décalez je suis en train
de dire que pardon pardon la question
est que faites-vous je réponds sur ce
qu'on fait et je suis interrompue pour
dire pour parler sur autre chose parce
que Monsieur de la porte n'est pas c'est
ma réponse elle est simple aussi écoutez
là écoutez je vous ai demandé pourquoi
vous refusiez la demande des étudiants
alors
attendez attendez tous les deux monsieur
de la porte à la question pourquoi vous
ne généralisez pas madame la ministre a
répondu parce que tous les étudiants ne
méritent pas de bénéficier de ce type
d'aide vous parliez des repas à Euro
vous répondez mais il y en a quand même
80 % qui en ont besoin voilà on en était
là et du départ on va se passer à autre
chose et qui avait un fond de 60
millions d'euros donc on a lancé avec la
première ministre et que ces
associations justement qui fonctionnent
aussi beaucoup avec des bénévoles elle
permettent à des étudiants de se nourrir
et la question d'après qui m'a été posée
c'est que faisait vous que faites-vous
avec le gouvernement pour soutenir ces
jeunes et j'ai répondu sur la question
du plafonnement notamment des loyers et
de la question des CROUS qui aujourd'hui
sont très mobilisées la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche Sylvie Retailleau les
ammobilisés à augmenter ses crédits
justement pour que ces jeunes puissent
être logés dans des histoires on va
demander juste qui permet de poursuivre
leurs études sereinement le plus
sereinement possible de la porte
reformuler face à la ministre et on en
s'enrera ce que vous vous souhaiteriez
ils ont pas eu de réponse à la question
que nous avons proposé est défendu à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est-à-dire le
repas à 1 euro pour tous les étudiants
ça avait permis de multiplier par 5 le
nombre de repas étudiants qui étaient
délivré c'était important ça a été utile
pendant le covid et surtout ça
bénéficier à tous et notamment ceux qui
sont au-dessus des seuils des bourses
mais qui ne vivent absolument pas dans
le luxe
je vous ai répondu sur sur la question
des banques alimentaires
et j'avais porté dans le la loi pouvoir
d'achat cet été un amendement pour
permettre notamment au bénévoles des
Restos du Coeur qui étaient face à la
hausse des prix de l'énergie d'avoir un
crédit d'impôt pour pouvoir se rendre et
faire les aider dans leur bénévolat
c'est un moment avait été refusé par la
majorité on a réussi à le faire voter
dans le budget dans le projet de loi de
financement de notre projet de loi de
finance et il est malheureux pas été
retenu après le 49-3 est-ce que vous
pensez pas qu'il y a une inégalité quand
on est bénévole et qu'on paye des impôts
on peut avoir une déduction fiscale
parce qu'on a des frais et quand on n'a
pas les moyens et qu'on est quand même
bénévole et ben là on paye plein pot ça
c'est pas normal je trouve une question
très intéressante que vous soulevez je
vous le dis sincèrement d'abord je vous
remercie de citer les Restos du coeur
parce que dans le palmarès des
associations préférées des Français ils
arrivent en numéro 1 on les a cités
aujourd'hui ils arrivent en numéro 1
pour les raisons que vous évoquez parce
qu'ils sont là dans les moments on a des
épreuves et des temps de fragilité votre
question elle est intéressante parce
qu'elle rejoint le Tour de France du
bénévolat qu'on organise en ce moment et
dont l'étape d'Île-de-France avait lieu
aujourd'hui au ministère et ces
questions on se les pose mais elle
mérite d'être travaillées je pense que
sur la question de la fiscalité
associative je parlais tout à l'heure de
notre volonté de simplifier il y a
encore des progrès à faire et je pense
qu'on peut mettre sur la table la
manière de valoriser cet engagement par
exemple moi je porte la VAE pour les
bénévoles le fait de dire la validation
des acquis de l'expérience pardon pour
les bénévoles aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui
est bénévole dans une association je
considère qu'on doit pouvoir valoriser
cet engagement et lui donner une
équivalence dans un diplôme pour dire
voilà vous avez acquis des compétences
vous avez fait des choses et ça va leur
de diplôme donc moi je prends votre
point et je m'engage à étudier cette
question que vous évoquez et à vous
revenir dès la fin du tour de France du
bénévolat donc dans les mois à venir
voilà dans les avant le mois du Juin
disons pour qu'on puisse avoir ensemble
si ça fait partie des pistes qui sont
plébiscitées par les bénévoles ça
l'engagement que je prends c'était une
demande que j'avais eu notamment des
bénévoles des Restos du cœur que j'ai
porté dans le Parlement qui a été refusé
par vos collègues de la majorité par
votre gouvernement
ne vote pas qui avait donné un avis
défavorable à cet amendement et la
majorité qui avait suivi le gouvernement
ça c'est la réalité aujourd'hui vous
vous engagez en tout cas étudier le
dossier de la place où vous êtes et cela
à Gabriel non mais je transmettrai à
moi-même puisque je suis en train de vie
associative
elle est encore une question
de la précarité étudiante et plus
largement il y a la précarité qui est
d'ordre économique face à la hausse des
prix mais il y a aussi la précarité
psychique et donc vous avez mis en place
un plan pour donner des consultations
gratuites jusqu'à 8 d'une demi-heure
mais c'est absolument pas suffisant face
à l'ampleur des besoins vous savez à
l'université de Caen aujourd'hui il y a
4 psy qui sont pas tous à temps plein
pour 33000 étudiants et c'est le cas
partout en France alors qu'il y a des
besoins qui sont énormes et dans les
pays voisins on a des situations on a à
peu près 10 fois plus de psy par
étudiant donc on a vraiment un retard en
France c'est absolument pas suffisant et
c'est un sujet énorme quand on sait
qu'il y a à peu près un tiers des
étudiants qui déclarent avoir des des
troubles psychiques donc ça c'est c'est
un sujet qu'il faut absolument mettre
sur la table et ça lui par ailleurs
puisque c'est la journée de l'engagement
l'engagement des jeunes Nightline
l'association Nightline qui s'implique
dans la question de la précarité
psychique notamment pour
l'accompagnement déjà mais le
gouvernement doit agir et surtout
recruter des psy à l'université parce
que c'est pas en donnant des chèques
qu'on y arrivera et qu'on répondra à la
demande maintenant vous avez raison moi
je partage votre constat et je partage y
compris la comparaison avec des pays
européens mais on voit que la place de
la psychiatrie en France vont l'histoire
elle a été longue douloureuse et
difficile à mettre en place nous on a
levé depuis 2017 avec Emmanuel Macron on
a levé le numéro US clausus on s'est
engagé justement à pouvoir former
davantage de psychiatre pour qu'on
puisse y avoir accès y compris dans les
lycées dans les universités je vous
rejoins là aussi et d'ailleurs on
parlait de la question du covid le
confinement a eu un impact que je pense
on ne mesure pas encore sur les jeunes
sur les adolescents les étudiants cette
génération qu'il y a en fait perdu deux
ans de sa jeunesse dans laquelle elle ne
pouvait pas sortir de chez elle donc je
vous rejoins sur cette urgence le
gouvernement fait tout ce qui est en son
pouvoir pour faire en sorte de libérer
cela mais c'est vrai que ça prend du
temps de former les psychiatres l'échecs
ne sont peut-être pas suffisants mais en
tout cas ils sont première démarche
c'est inédit c'est la première fois
qu'un gouvernement s'engage à financer
des consultations chez un psy chez des
jeunes et en vrai suivi pas juste une
consultation lui consultation
non mais je suis bien d'accord avec vous
c'est un travail de longue haleine un
travail difficile qui rejoint la
question de la désertification médicale
et de l'attractivité de ces professions
on a besoin aujourd'hui d'attirer de
recruter déjà qui vont être des
étudiants en psychiatrie de venir des
psychiatres pour ensuite avoir un vrai
maillage territorial sur ce sujet et
plus largement ça pose la question du
système de santé universitaire parce que
là en fait on a une rustine enfin on
essaie de trouver une rustine en
envoyant vers la médecine de ville
finalement les étudiants alors qu'il
devrait être pris en charge à la fac
avec un accompagnement gratuit parce que
voilà on le disait tout à l'heure la
plupart des étudiants n'ont pas les
moyens de se payer eux-mêmes
professionnels de santé c'est vrai aussi
pour les lycées moi je suis maman
d'adolescente et d'élèves et c'est vrai
que dans les lycées vous n'avez vous
avez aujourd'hui des petits remarquables
et je veux les saluer mais vous n'en
avez peut-être pas suffisamment ça
dépend des lycées il y a une question de
maillage territorial forte et là encore
ça rejoint la question qu'on évoquait
sur les gynécologues tout à l'heure ce
que vous dites pour les étudiants et
tout à fait vrai y compris pour des
femmes qui veulent avoir accès à la
contraception qui n'ont pas de
rendez-vous chez le gynécologue qui vont
vers le médecin généraliste et
aujourd'hui à Caen et même à Paris c'est
extrêmement long pour trouver un
praticien qui souhaite vous prendre
comme nouveau patient et être votre
médecin traitant c'est très difficile un
tour sur doctolib suffit à son
convaincre et c'est face à ça qu'on fait
ce CNR santé avec François Brune le
ministre de la Santé pour remonter
toutes les bonnes pratiques libérées du
temps médical libérer là aussi du temps
administratif c'est pour ça que le
président a lancé les assistants
médicaux pour permettre à chaque
praticien qui soit médecin généraliste
gynécologue de voir véritablement ces
passions et de leur apporter un suivi de
qualité c'était pour rebondir sur ce que
vous disiez à l'instant c'est à dire que
les solutions vous pensez que le CNR
santé va les inventer mais elles
existent déjà en fait finalement les
solutions pour lutter contre la
désertification médicale on aurait pu en
débattre et j'aurais aimé en débattre
malheureusement le 49-3 sur le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale a fait qu'on n'a pas eu ce débat
notamment sur la meilleure manière de
lutter contre les déserts médicaux
aujourd'hui en France vous avez des
zones où vous avez un psy par exemple
pour 40 000 habitants alors que dans
d'autres à Bordeaux en Gironde
c'était des obligations d'installation
pour mieux régler mieux répartir l'offre
de santé malheureusement le gouvernement
a refusé d'avoir ce débat avec nous et
donc on est un peu désemparé parce que
l'installation mais d'abord vous pouvez
pas blâmer le fait qu'un CNR existe et
le fait qu'il y ait une consultation oui
bah bien sûr l'urgence elle est là je ça
fait des années que je le dis et qu'on
est nombreux à dire je veux pas être
désobligeante et faire de la politique
politicienne mais enfin il y a un
quinquennat et demi sous François
Hollande l'urgence elle était déjà là
moi j'étais élue en Sarthe à l'époque et
j'appelais au gouvernement à l'aide en
disant nous avons un énorme problème de
désertification médicale qui a des
conséquences graves des gens qui
embolisent aujourd'hui les urgences
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de médecin
traitant pour leurs enfants l'obligation
d'installation c'est une solution mais
ça moi je vais vous dire non parce que
par exemple vous vous balayez d'un
revers de main le CNR moi j'ai assisté à
un CNR en cercle CNRS sont les soignants
donc moi je veux bien que tout le monde
c'est tout mieux que les soignants
eux-mêmes mais le CNR sont les soignants
qui partagent leurs solutions et qui dit
ce dont ils ont besoin et comment on
doit
d'abord levé le numerus clausus c'est
une première chose ensuite on forme pas
un médecin en claquant des doigts on
forme pas un psychiatre en 30 secondes
ni même en un an la même l'obligation
d'installation je suis après c'est après
la formation bien évidemment mais ce que
nous disent aujourd'hui les soignants
c'est que ce n'est pas pour eux une
solution pérenne et efficace et si on
avait ce traité ce sujet il y a 7 ans ou
10 ans quand François Hollande était
président de la République nous n'en
serions pas là aujourd'hui c'est la
durée non mais si vous voulez c'est la
durée de formation d'un médecin si
François Hollande a son élection s'était
dit ah bah tiens je vais peut-être
écouter des élus locaux qui comme
Marlène Schiappa nous c'est fini
désertification territoriales il n'était
pas ministre de la santé mais vous étiez
avec François Hollande et c'est un sujet
qu'on aurait pu mettre sur la table
aujourd'hui ce sont les Français qui
merci et c'est Emmanuel Macron qui
apporte des solutions merci à Arthur de
la porte d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui face à
machin c'était un peu chaud mais
intéressant ça va on peut faire voilà on
peut faire mieux je vous le confirme
Vincent roux vous êtes revenu avec nous
Vincent roux avec une question
importante aussi tiens grosse question
de réflexion grande question de
réflexion allez-y Vincent
à la fin de la semaine il va y avoir
l'installation de la convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie alors est-ce
qu'il va y avoir vraiment un débat sur
la question
bien est-ce que c'est un habillage les
jeux sont faits et on va se préparer
avoir un texte qui va légaliser
l'euthanasie
non vous savez le président de la
République a vraiment été attaché à une
chose très forte c'est qu'il soit
vraiment l'unité de notre pays et à
chaque fois que le pays se fracture ou
se divise y compris sur des enjeux de
société il considère que c'est un
constat d'échec et que ces grandes
réformes là qui touchent à l'intime qui
touche au plus grand tabou de la vie au
plus grand mystère de la vie aussi
c'est-à-dire la mort mais aussi la
douleur la fin de vie la perte de proche
ça doit pouvoir être un sujet qui nous
réunisse et non pas qui nous fracture
donc l'idée pour lui pour le président
de la République n'est pas d'en faire un
drapeau ou une victoire politique mais
au contraire d'apporter des réponses à
des situations de grandes souffrances
qui existent aujourd'hui et de laisser
le débat se faire c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il y a cette manière de
travailler avec des citoyens pour
s'écouter notamment avec le CESU pour
que chacun puisse avoir voix au chapitre
Vincent vous avez votre réponse j'ai ma
réponse j'ai juste une question puisque
c'est connexe au débat qui vient d'avoir
il y a un problème qui ressort quand
même et à chaque à chaque débat sur
cette question là parce que ça fait 20
ans donc on en débat c'est la question
des soins palliatifs il y a un
engagement légal à avoir dans tous les
départements des unités permanentes ce
qui n'est absolument pas le cas
aujourd'hui c'est pas ça la priorité
plutôt
est-ce que ça n'est pas plutôt ça la
priorité moi je veux pas préempter le
débat je pense que bien sûr ça fait
partie des dispositions c'est vrai qu'on
en a débattu à l'époque pendant la loi
classe Léonetti qui a donné lieu à cette
loi un peu de compromis dirais avec des
guillemets à compromis et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des dispositions
légales qui existent les soins
palliatifs vous l'avez mentionné mais
aussi le fait de pouvoir mettre par
écrit sa volonté et de la donner à un
tiers de confiance pour qu'elle répéter
quelle qu'elle soit respectée pardon
quelle qu'elle soit c'est-à-dire que la
volonté soit de souffrir le moins
possible et partir vite mais que la
volonté soit aussi de pouvoir rester en
soins palliatifs si c'est le choix de la
personne il doit être respecté aussi
parce que c'est un appel à de l'intime à
des convictions personnelles parfois
religieuses et qui sont toutes
parfaitement respectables merci beaucoup
Vincent roux encore une toute petite
question il reste quelques secondes en
Iran les femmes les hommes les
manifestants pour l'instant ne plient
pas face à la rue alors les mots là
samedi ont annoncé que ils abolissaient
la police des mœurs mais sur place la
population ne croit pas à ce qu'elle
demande c'est à dire un changement
profond de régime
c'était le 16 septembre le début du
mouvement aujourd'hui on est cinq
décembre 300 morts au moins que vous
inspire cette révolution non mais
d'abord beaucoup de respect pour le
courage immense des femmes iraniennes et
des hommes aussi qui les soutiennent et
effectivement moi je les soutiens
pleinement depuis le premier jour et je
soutiens leur pour que les femmes
puissent sortir cheveux au vent en Iran
en France comme partout dans le monde la
France les soutiens le président de la
République a d'ailleurs reçu
personnellement à l'Elysée des femmes
qui sont des leaders de cette révolution
iranienne et nous sommes à leur côté
merci infiniment malienne avoir été
l'invité d'audition publique merci
encore une fois Monsieur de la porte on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine bien
sûr lundi 19h30 pour un prochain numéro
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]